somebody suggested to do a part three of
why lex is single there's a running joke
about this
uh so yeah
but i can answer it in part right yeah
because well partially because you're
very busy partially because um you've
decided that
until it's time you're gonna
wait until it's time it's time right i
mean until it's time you're waiting and
then um you're not saving yourself for
marriage uh i think but but in some
sense um yeah your your wife your future
wife is out there oh yeah yeah she's
being programmed no i uh i mean i
definitely i definitely believe that i
mean first of all i i just love people
and i fall in love very easily with
people with objects with things with
with life with every moment and that way
you're like oliver sacks he fell he
would fall in love with minerals
and concepts and things like that and so
like to me this kind of
uh so relationship is more like a
commitment to one particular kind of
um
object of your love
like uh it's almost like a
it's like a journey that you take on
together because also the interesting
thing about humans
is they're moment by moment a different
person day by day week by week month by
month they change they evolve there's an
ups and downs and stuff like that so
you're what you're doing is you're
saying well i'm going to explore all the
ways that this human gets
morphed and changed and the
what makes them cry what makes them
excited what makes them
uh lonely
uh like the
the the habits how like when they form
certain habits what
how they feel when those habits are
broken like the stupid my new things
that make everyday life you're gonna be
on that journey together figuring that
out just the way we're trying to figure
ourselves out
when we're like optimizing these things
about diet and health so on you're kind
of doing this
computation together because neither
person really understands themselves
at all and you're together both confused
about each other and you get to almost
like um
a relationship is a chance
to understand yourself
and
to understand another person
like together that process is some kind
it's something i'm all iterative you
know the dynamics right i mean you're
merging two nervous systems one this was
once described to me very well by an
ex-girlfriend um who's
truly brilliant she's really brilliant
um
she said you know there's four arrows
this is maybe to an engineer or like a
so makes sense there's how you feel
towards the other person yes there's how
they feel towards you but then there's
an there's an arrow that comes back to
you
which is how you feel about how
they feel
and then they have an arrow of how they
feel about how you feel right this is
why if someone else is moody or somebody
else is upset it
there's one version of ourselves where
we respond to that or they respond to us
but there's another version where we
respond to that but it's also there's a
processing of what it means for us that
they're behaving that way or feeling
that way and this again
leads us back to that early attachment
circuitry because if a parent
was stressed
the child's role is not to soothe the
parent
in fact healthy models of parenting say
that children shouldn't actually know
how their parents feel for like the
first eight years of their life they're
not supposed to be in that mindset of
empathizing for the parent this is often
not the case but and maybe the cutoff
isn't exactly eight but you get the idea
so the dynamics of a relationship are
where the learning is because we learn
how we react to other people reacting
it's it's not a just a two-arrow system
it's at least this four-arrow thing um
but there's also the element of
nurturing right i mean i think that um
going through life with somebody is so
much better than going through it alone
and i i never thought i'd make that
statement
um
so it wasn't always obvious to you no it
wasn't always obvious to me i've been
i've really enjoyed wonderful
relationships um
and some have been hard and and there's
been certainly been a lot of growth i'm
on good terms with almost all my
former girlfriends um and close with
some enough that i'm i know their
spouses and i'm close with their
families and um but no it wasn't and i
think that
when people say relationship is hard the
only really hard part about of a good
relationship is just dealing with
oneself and making sure that you're
staying in that
mode of care taking cause i do believe
that if
one is mainly focused on taking good
care of the other person provided
they're also focused on taking good care
of you
to some extent and we're good at taking
care of ourselves everybody flourishes
everything gets better but no i don't
think i experienced that until fairly
recently um what do you think is the uh
secret to a successful relationship
there isn't just one but at at least at
in the top five is
master or at least be
good at
autonomic self-regulation know how to
calm yourself down
don't expect the like looking to
anything external to soothe yourself as
it puts you in a terrible position to to
be a caretaker of yourself and other
people right so learn how to self-soothe
right learn how to
calm your mind steady your actions
steady your voice there are tools to do
that we talk about on the podcast but
elsewhere have that in place i also
think that if
if your main focus is on
you want to have good boundaries etc but
on
tending to the relationship doing a
little bit more than you think you ought
to do if everyone does that it goes
great i mean i'm sometimes so positively
struck by how supported i feel
um
because for many years i was just kind
of doing everything on my own so any
little thing i'm like oh my goodness
this feels huge um and also i think the
dynamics have to be right let's let's be
really honest this is a little bit of a
tricky topic but um
there is a power dynamic in
relationships
sometimes not all but in some
relationships it works much better if
one person leads and the other person
follows in other relationships it's more
mutuality works best people need to know
what they need and so knowing what you
need and what you crave
is really important and then once you do
that you can
create the relationship you want i've
seen that over and over again and people
are different um but i think that um
ultimately i mean right it's it's
there's the dopamine phase of a
relationship and then there's the
serotonin phase the kind of more
mutuality coziness and sweetness there's
a great book about how to make sure that
the dopamine component and the
serotonin component so to speak go on
forever and it has to do with you know
when you first meet someone you're
attracted to them you're essentially
objectifying them you meaning not in the
way people might think you are
not dependent on them for emotional
stability or survival as you get close
with somebody you really come to depend
on them and then you tend to objectify
them less and so this book the book is
the name is kind of corny but it's
written by an analyst again it's called
can love last and it's a book about how
really good strong relationships are the
consequence of people constantly moving
through this
dependency objectification dynamic
and i use those words in the true
in the psychological sense not in the
way they're typically thrown around
nowadays so the id you know in some
cultures
men and women
will
only touch for two weeks out of the
month
and then for the other two weeks
the
excitement and the sensuality and all
and the sexuality is very heightened
and then they go back to this kind of
distancing now i don't think that's
feasible for most people but if you look
statistically those relationships tend
to last a very long time with at least
reported
mutual feelings of intense attraction
for
many many many decades
so human beings need to learn how to
at least understand and control these
dynamics there's a lot of divorce
there's a lot of cheating there's a lot
of stuff out there it'd be great if
people could resolve some of this stuff
inside of the relationship in my opinion
yeah and this kind of intense attraction
i
there's uh actually uh one of the poems
that carl uh daiseroth introduced me to
i think two english poems is the name
but
one of the
things i find myself for prolonged
periods being attracted to
is like
you notice some kind of magic
and you keep wanting to dig to the
depths like
of that magic you're trying to really
know that person to really know a person
deeply yeah
you notice something yeah early on sure
i don't know what that is but you just
notice something special and you want to
keep pulling at that thread
and you never really do well you also
have to be careful you know i get a lot
of questions from god you have to be
careful the questions you ask in a
relationship too you have to make sure
you really want that information and
it's not just about people's past right
if you ask somebody how they really feel
about something about you and they tell
you
that may be soothing it may be intensely
stressful you have to be
here's one thing i know for sure
for a relationship to work you have to
be brave
you can't go in there fully protected
and yet you also can't go in there with
no boundaries because you'll end up
beat up what's that quote if you want to
be a warrior prepare to get hurt if you
want to be an explorer prepare to get
lost and if you want to be both you know
if you become a lover prepare to be both
or something something like that i
forget this is one of these instagram
type things that you see passing by and
you know that's pretty true love love
scary because it takes us back to that
primitive circuitry that is as primitive
and basic as hunger thirst the desire
for heat when we're cold the desire for
cold when we're
overly
warm
it's a
it's dynorphin i mean when somebody
leaves like the you know when somebody
you are attached to
leaves by death or by decision
or you're forced apart the dinorphin
release is massive it is true discomfort
people
feel anxiety and discomfort and moving
through that is a hell of a process i
mean if i knew how to best break up at
the neurological level or if you just
plug yourself into a wall and reset
i mean i do that episode tomorrow but we
don't have that knowledge
come on the uh i think we've covered
this before and it's even been munified
i think losing love is part of the magic
of love it means you've felt something i
agree but at some point like have you
done it enough times
you know
life is finite you know it is beautiful
to see these couples that seem very much
in love despite
many years despite having been together
many years yeah the way they look at
each other yeah they'll say they still
see the magic yeah and they'll say we
got lucky or it was it's been hard or
this and that i think
external conditions being a little
tougher is helpful for a couple
hardship i do i do because i think that
you rally you know you you and you bond
with people you know being obviously you
want to survive those conditions but um
yeah i do i think that bonnie and clyde
so and they were a little
a little too much
well a little bit too much they were at
sociopaths but the uh
well when two sociopaths [ __ ] can
make you do crazy normally it's
interesting normally sociopaths don't
team up
because they because they manipulate
each other
sociopaths sadly are um are usually only
interested in manipulating the highly
pliable or unsuspecting um but when
romantic attraction is woven in
then it gets
um
really diabolical any advice on finding
the love of your
life of my life this is this is uh why
lex's single response why any advice
yeah actually this comes from a friend
of mine who's in a really excellent
marriage um with
great kids and family and high demand
life
it's a decision like at some point you
just priority you just prioritize it as
okay
i'm going to make this happen one way or
another and um you don't force the
discovery of that person but i mean i've
occasionally said hey i think you should
meet this person or that person and um
well it wasn't maybe my judgment was
might have been off but the timing
wasn't right or something but i think
that yeah it's a decision
and it also has to do with life
structure i mean there were years so i
when i was in graduate school
i didn't want a girlfriend i just wanted
to be in lab and i sure i had romantic
dating interests but i wasn't going to
meet them through a committed you know
live together situation
wasn't where i was at and as a postdoc
here things are a little different
cetera et cetera so but at some point
it's sort of like what do i want my
daily routine to look like because
ultimately a relationship
however one structures is gonna be part
of your daily routine so at the point
where you're like you know i'd really
love to wake up next to somebody and do
blank and blank together and then i'd
love to
work and then we meet for dinner and
then we you know take the dog for a walk
or take kids out or whatever it happens
to be take a trip but do you have to be
one has to be in the mindset of wanting
to do couple-like things people and a
lot of people don't think about it that
way they they either fall into something
or they
they don't see the benefits of
coupling up i think that the pandemic
tuned people's awareness to
the fact that some things are indeed
easier on your own
depends on finances etc etc but
a lot of things are made better
done with other people
100 percent but i also so
i was very deliberately
it's an interesting way to put it like
what do you want your day to look like i
think what what do you want your day to
look like what you want your life to be
i was very deliberately always
uh first of all
happy to be alone
like a conscious thinking
i know a lot of friends were just unable
to be alone i'm able to be alone but i'm
much happier with another person like
i'm able to share joy with other humans
i look forward to the day that our kids
are rolling jiu jitsu and my kids are
you know
hanging out with your kids and
um if that notion sounds
even remotely interesting then
and fun then then it's sort of like you
kind of back pedal from that and you go
how do you guys
and think from first principles about
love
andrew you're uh
thank you for being my friend thank you
for being an amazing human being who's
so inspiring to so many people for
constantly i told us the car like one of
the things that was really refreshing
um about you
is that
you uh
when i tell you an idea and i tell you a
thought when i tell you something
you didn't you don't shut it down as a
first step saying that that's common in
a scientific community that's commonly
people around you you're you're seeing
what's the goal there you get excited
you get excited together and that's how
you can really
uh have a great friendship and a great
do great great stuff together so i i'm
deeply grateful for that and just
uh for connecting so many interesting
people together you're doing an amazing
job man and uh thank you for existing
thank you for being you thank you for
talking today and uh next time i'll see
you in the sauna and yeah yeah thanks
beth well i want to say several things
first of all thank you for having me on
again it's an honor and a pleasure and i
don't say that formally i really truly
mean it i only the humor in lab podcasts
as i always say only exists because you
gave me the suggestion and i'm so
grateful that you did so thank you and
for doing what you do like you you are
brave and you're first man in and you're
just continue to do it just what as my
postdoc advisor used to say whatever
you're doing
just keep going and then in terms of our
friendship i mean i think uh
you know and if you uh if you don't i'm
gonna just keep telling you anyway by
texting in person you're an amazing
friend uh there's deep trust there's
immense respect and
i love you brother i love you too man
we did it
you